good evening Fernando welcome to Piers
Morgan uncensored there's a common
assumption that the world is inevitably
going nuts the list of books Brands
movies songs ideas products people and
words deem defensive grows ever longer
those of us huddle together on the tiny
island of Common Sense will be gradually
submerged by the rising tide of lunacy
until the two spirit penguins are in
charge of the zoo but recently I've been
feeling the little green shoots of
optimism
there's a recovery from Oklahoma there's
a growing dossier of evidence that
actually most people don't think like
these idiots and have had enough of all
the woke nonsense at the end of last
week's Sebastian code the president of
the world Athletics Council one of
Britain's greatest athletes made this
announcement
the council has agreed to exclude male
to female transgender athletes who have
been through male puberty from female
world ranking competitions from March
the 31st
well Hallelujah
is it taking this long athletes born
male with their bigger stronger male
bodies and Superior muscle mass cannot
compete against women fairly it's just
not equal
so that's a big tree for common sense
last month the British prime minister
Richard sune startled me by saying this
the world's most controversial question
bizarrely has become what is a woman
yeah I of course I know a woman who
adult human female
incredible that was a question that
stumped secure Stone nearly the
opposition it stumped Supreme Court
justices in America is stump poor old
Nicholas sturgeon who's now lost her job
because she just couldn't work out what
a woman is
a politician finally having the guts to
actually say the obvious and not worry
about being condemned immediately is a
vicious bigger because he's not another
victory of your common sense the
shocking case of Isla Bryson the double
rapist who transitioned to become a
woman after after reaching trial and
then demanded a place in a female prison
where he would have been surrounded by
people he could then attack as he had
done before United the country in
disbelief
only Nicholas sturgeon the first
minister of Scotland didn't get that
memo
trans women are women but in the prison
context there is no automatic right for
a trans woman there are context where a
trans woman is not a woman no there is
there is circumstances in which a trans
woman will be housed in the male prison
estate
excruciating to watch one of the most
successful women in modern politics
literally end her career by not being
able to stand up for women's rights and
that complete failure of basic Common
Sense led to her departure well days
later one of the titans of British
policies was on the political Scrappy
isn't that a lesson for everybody else
if you go against Common Sense
eventually there will be a day of
reckoning this week's student to the U.S
University have been protesting the
decision to invite the state's Governor
Glenn Younkin potentially one of the
presidential candidates for next year to
make a speech his crime is being a
republican he's actually a reasonably
moderate Republican six thousand of
these snowflake students have signed the
petition to stop it
but remarkably instead of bowing to this
juvenile mob we just want to sit in
their little tank talking to each other
about the same things that they all
agree on as we become accustomed to
they've gone ahead and invited him
anyway
another victory for common sense or when
reporters discovered that so-called
sensitivity readers were purging classic
novels by Royal Darley and Fleming
Agatha Christie and so on cleansing them
even Eden blight and got brought into
this cleansing them of apparently
upsetting content the public said no
shut up stop this madness
we couldn't find anybody to come on this
show to defend it finally the Penny's
dropping and then we have the guardian
the global home of History bashing logic
defying virtue signaling workery we've
now had to issue a groveling massive
front page apology for itself for being
a bunch of racists founded by somebody
who employed slaves
which even the most humorless hard mode
signal as a virtue had been forced to
admit is actually very entertaining and
amusing for the rest of us and even
Hollywood seems to be finally stirring
too today Jennifer Aniston lamented the
fact publicly that many young people say
friends was offensive
the number of people saying
I can't believe it but I actually agree
with Piers Morgan is reaching historic
levels
it's getting very busy on Common Sense
Island
I think we're going to need a bigger
boat